okay so linear what's linear linear
means it's a first degree C
x-to-the-first and repeated means that
it's to a higher power than one like
squared cubed to the fourth power it
means you have this factor repeated okay
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
the decomposition the first thing you
want to look for those to see if it's an
improper fraction you can see this is x
squared if we were to foil this out this
would be X cubed the degree in the
numerator is lower than the degree in
the denominator so we don't have to do
long division and convert it so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
see how we're going to break this down
so what we're going to do is we already
have the denominator factored so it's
going to be ax this is going to be X
plus 1 and then we want to do X plus 1
squared okay if we just had you know X
plus 1 squared and not X plus 1 or X
plus 1 and not X plus 1 squared we
wouldn't be taking into account you know
all the possible fractions originally
before we combine them into one fraction
to get the fraction that we have here so
you could have this denominator and this
denominator when you combine them
together the common denominator is still
going to be X plus 1 squared so you have
to consider the fact that there may be a
fraction with just X plus 1 to the first
power ok so you want to take those into
account now if this was X plus 1 cubed
we would have X plus 1 X plus 1 squared
and then X plus 1 cubed but you can here
see here it's just to the second power
now the next thing is the numerator well
we know this is to the first degree it's
linear this has to be lower by one
degree that's going to be a constant
we're to call that a this is also linear
we want this to be one little degree
lower so we're going to call that B now
here's where students sometimes make a
mistake they see this this is x squared
and they think this will be like CX plus
D okay because they want it to be one
degree lower than that what they think
is x squared but because this is a
linear factor it's just X to the first
we're just going to make this a constant
C okay so just make note of that when
you're doing these problems it's not a
quadratic factor this is a linear factor
so this
it's going to be one degree lower okay
so now all we have to do is we just have
to clear the denominators and solve this
equation so we're going to multiply the
left and the right sides the entire
equation by the common denominator this
is the common denominator here x times X
plus 1 squared so when we multiply each
of these fractions by that quantity we
clear the denominators and we're left
with 5x squared plus 11x plus 2 here the
X's are going to cancel out we're going
to have a times X plus 1 squared plus
here we're going to have B times X times
another X plus 1 because one of the X
plus ones is going to cancel and then
the third one when we multiply we're
going to be left with C times X so we've
cleared the denominators by multiplying
through by this common denominator okay
so what do we need to do now well we're
going to be strategic and we're going to
say let's let X equal zero because if we
do that zero times anything is zero
that's going to cancel out these two
groups and we can solve for a so let's
let X equal zero x equals zero so that's
going to make this 0 plus 0 plus 2
equals 0 plus 1 is 1 1 squared is 1
that's going to be a ok so we solve for
a let's be strategic again let's set X
equal to negative 1 that'll cancel this
term in this term will be able to solve
for C okay so let's do that so we put x
equals negative 1 we get negative 1
squared is 1 times 5 is 5 okay plus
negative 11 is negative 6 plus 2 is
negative 4 okay negative 1 plus 1 that's
going to make this 0 that's gonna make
this 0 that's going to make this
negative C so you can see that C equals
positive 4 now all we're left to solve
for is B well there's we can't cancel
anything out by being strategic by
setting X to a certain value to cancel
out some of the other terms so why don't
we just let X equal positive 1 okay so
we're going to say x equals 1 we put in
1 here we get 11 plus 5 is 16 plus 2 is
18 a we already know is 2 and we're
putting 1 in for X that's 1 plus 1/2
two squared is four okay B we don't know
times 1 times 1 plus 1 is 2 so that's
going to be B times 2 plus C we know is
4 so that's 4 times 1 which is 4 now we
can solve the equation for B so what do
we have here we've got 8 plus 4 is 12
subtract the 12 that's going to give you
6 equals 2b so by dividing we get B
equals 3 now we know a B and C and if we
go ahead and put these back in you can
see that these would be your original
fractions before you combine them
together to get this fraction here so we
decomposed it we broke it down into the
original fractions prior to to adding
them together so again this is a good
technique you know by picking certain
values for X to cancel out some of the
terms but sometimes you'll get to the
point where you know you'll have to just
pick up a value like we did here at the
end we substituted x equals 1 in and we
use the the other values that we solved
for already now if we had a couple other
variables left over we'd have to solve a
system and I can show you how that works
in some of the other videos so I'll see
in the next video